alright Lucy we have a tongue forward
here we have a common project gap we
have advanced it seems like there's
every price point everyone's playing in
this game I feel like we've been
longtime supporters of the slip-on
especially Vance which we have here but
I think that this is a stylish shoe that
guys don't realize is stylish and we're
basically gonna tell you why the stylish
which ones to buy and how to wear them
starting with the CDs a little bit of a
throwback something you've probably seen
buying these things in everywhere this
is what my grandpa used to wear simple
stylish canvas lots of different colors
lots of styles all gonna be comfortable
off in a casual can you wear like a cash
sock with that kind of like skater yeah
I feel like that works with advanced
especially and we've always loved fans
might be the first step on we've ever
even shot I don't think I've ever seen
that colorway before is that you've not
seen this this is the 50th anniversary
sneaker or one of the 50th anniversary
sneakers all done in leather super color
vlogs the sneakers honestly amazing any
cool kid in California will definitely
be skateboarding in those shoes this
song that braided woven leather woven
leather you could literally wear like an
all white all black all grey all Navy
look and this is really all you need
next up gap this is where our price
point really comes into play anyone can
buy this okay love love this is honest
thing I would say it's more of your city
shoe take that Jean make a raw edge cut
it off at the bottom show a little ankle
this is a total summer sneaker I love
that it's not your classic camel with
the green it has the gray and the Blues
kind of tonal you could wear that with
anything yeah I mean you really could
wear this with the black Jean and
totally dress it up but I think the
print is just really on point these last
few you have the Tom Ford and you have
the common project sock it wear with a
suit really dresses it up make sure you
tailor your suit so it fits perfectly
Tom Ford we have suede here it can
literally be worn as a dress shoe this
obviously is gorgeous and this is
probably your easier one to transition
to
this would actually look amazing with us
ooh make sure your pin line hits it
correctly and basically just use it as
you would a dress shoe but it's your
slip on sneaker there you have it you
can either wear these slip ons to the
beach you can kick it around the city or
you can dress it up with a suit
regardless now you have the five best
ones for this summer